- My mind is like (exploding).
(upbeat instrumental music)
- I've literally never
heard of this before.
- I'm extremely nervous because
I don't know if this is gonna ruin
a lot of my favorite foods for me.
- I'm scared it won't work on me
and then I'll find out I have like
faulty taste buds or something.
- This looks like drugs.
- It tastes how I image
potpourri would taste.
- I am ready to flavor trip balls.
- Whoa.
- Oh my god.
Did you put like sugar in this?
- It's so good.
- I've got actually eat an entire
bag of lemons on this stuff.
- Oh my god.
That tastes fucking delicious.
It tastes like lemonade.
- Let's just fill that right up.
- It tastes like Barefoot Moscato that you
buy when you have like
three dollars in college.
- This is like Capri Sun.
Like I don't taste anything
besides like juice.
- This just tastes like
watered down coffee.
- This tastes like water.
- It tastes like pee.
I have tasted pee before.
- Oh god, that was disgusting.
- If I drank this and somebody
told me it was apple juice,
I'd be like you need to throw this out.
This is like a week past
the expiration date,
- That was more pleasant than I expected.
- It's still just as potent as
you'd expected apple cider vinegar to be.
But it's sweet.
- This is so weird.
How long does this last, forever?
- It made it spicier.
That's so rude.
- This is like a...
(yelling)
Alright, I'm not eating that one.
- Has it ruined my trip?
Has the jalapeno ruined my flavor trip?
- This is my worst enemy.
- I hate grapefruit, it tastes like bile.
- Whoa, wow.
This tastes like a tangerine.
This is so sweet.
- That's so good.
- I can't believe
grapefruits are not trash
and nobody told me that.
- That was probably one of the most
life changing experiences I've had.
- I will not do this again.
- It was fun.
- I hope I don't get addicted to like
little flavored taste
bud messer upper pills.
- I'm supposed to have dinner after this.
It's all gonna taste like chewy candy.
(upbeat instrumental music)
This is nasty.
A coated Advil tastes better than this.
It's like a sick reject Flintstones gummy.
Tastes like how I imagine a
Gucci perfume might taste.
Like expensive but disgusting.